Uh, let's see who is next?
Uh, let's go to our caller from the five Oh
three area code.
Who's calling today from five zero three.
Hello?
Yeah, that's, yeah.
Okay, cool.
Sorry, my area code is off.
I live in Idaho now, but, uh, my name's Austin.
Um, I just had a question regarding the 2020
election and you know, there's a couple like
left wing commentators on YouTube and whatnot
that have brought this up in the past.
Um, Tom is one of them.
Damn Cedar just did a segment not too long
ago.
And it's regarding the idea about, you know,
Trump attempting to invalidate the result
if he in fact loses.
I haven't been one to sign onto that idea
or that notion for a while now.
Um, but the more and more I watch bill BARR
and the more and more, you know, this impeachment
rolls out and I see the public reaction on
the right, uh, you know, Trump's base reacting
to the impeachment and their rhetoric rounded.
I'm really worried that there is a significant
possibility of maybe not at being successful,
but it being very, very damaging to our country,
you know, longterm.
Um, um, you know, to our institutions to,
you know, public opinion about, you know,
how politics works or how elections are supposed
to work.
And I just want to make a few points on that
and maybe let you respond to them.
Um, so my first point to that would be, you
know, what do you need to try to use sir power
or you know, and validate electrons alter,
you know, establish itself as an authoritarian,
whatever.
Um, well you would need enough public support,
right?
Obviously you would need enough public support
and you would need like a die hard, almost
cultish like following, um, and Trump has
that, you know, we, you've talked about, you
and other people have talked about the, you
know, almost one third of the country that's
very, very supportive, almost caught like
of the president and obviously his support
might be higher than that, but there's that
one third that never breaks.
Right.
Then you have the backing in the Congress,
you guys didn't Republicans that so far and,
and people in the house, as you say, Republican,
that's so far we haven't found something that
they're really willing to not eventually just
break on and follow Trump on.
Right.
Eventually they break even if they give like
flowery, you know, rhetoric against him.
Eventually they do.
And then you have, and then the Supreme court,
I want to mention that as well.
And then the scariest of the mall in my opinion
is bill BARR.
I mean, bill BARR, to me, if this was ever
to go down, bill BARR would be the one to
try to hold it up legally in the Supreme court
and make an anti things up in the Supreme
court legally making the case that there was
some sort of fraud, that there was some re
there's some reason to, you know, postpone
the election results and keep Trump in power
temporarily.
And, uh, he'd be the person trying to work
that route.
And then Trump would be the person, you know,
doing the PR campaign around it.
And I think bill unfortunately might be the
brain.
So here's my thought.
Okay.
I think I understand.
So here's my sense.
Um, I think it is very likely that if Donald
Trump loses, he will informally try to question
the results to claim that it was an unfair
election to claim that he was robbed to claim
that he didn't really lose.
I don't think it will actually be anything
that becomes formal for a couple of reasons.
Number one, although he has that third support,
I think it is very likely that whether Trump
wins or loses the electoral college, he's
going to lose the popular vote much like he
did in 2016 maybe, maybe by even more.
And typically for these types of, you know,
for staying in power in that to work you often
need to have the military behind you.
And I don't think Trump has the military and
the generals.
It's insane to me to say this because normally
we don't say we'll be okay because of the
generals in the military.
Often we're trying to restrain them in what
they're going to do.
But I actually think that if Donald Trump
tried to remain in power, uh, I don't believe
that the military would allow it and I don't
think that he would succeed.
So I fully expect that he is going to try
a lot of the things you're saying.
I do not believe that it will work.
Can I just ask one more quick, really, really
quick follow up.
What would, what would bill Barr's role or,
or influence be over the military in fact
event?
Like, cause you said, you know, he could handcuff
him to the desk of the oval office, but eventually
they come in, remove them, doesn't it?
Doesn't that doesn't that order or that request
go to bill bar first and then he says, okay,
go, wait.
What, what influence does he have?
I don't know.
You know, I don't want to give the wrong answer,
but I don't, I think ultimately it would be
up to the military to say Trump is no longer
president and he has to go and there's no
question that bill BARR through the justice
department could try to do things.
But ultimately I don't believe that it is
up to bar as bad of a player as bar is.
I don't think in that case bar's the one who
decides.
I may be wrong and we should look into it,
but I don't think so.
Okay.
Thank you so much.
David.
Loved the show.
Happy holidays.
Thank you so much.
Appreciate the phone call.
Happy holidays to you.
Uh, that is all the time we have today.
Sorry to everybody did not get to, but we
will take calls again.
Still more opportunities to get on the air
with us this year.
We will take a quick break
and be back with so much more right after
this.